so I have a box and whiskers plot
showing us the ages of students at a
party and what I'm hoping to do in this
video is get a little bit of practice
interpreting this and what I have here
are five different statements and I want
you to look at these statements pause
the video look at these statements and
think about which of these based on the
information in the box and whiskers plot
which of these are for short true which
is these are for sure' false and which
of these we don't have enough
information it could go either way
all right so let's let's work through
these so the first statement is that all
of the students are less than 17 years
old well we see right over here that the
maximum age that's the right end of this
right or whisker is 16 so it is the case
that all of the students are less than
17 years old so this is definitely going
to be true the next statement at least
75% of the students are 10 years old or
older so when you look at this this
feels right because 10 is 10 is the
value that is at the beginning of the
second quartile this is the second
quartile right over there and actually
let me do this let me do this in a
different color so this is the second
quartile so 25% of the value of the
numbers are in the second or roughly its
note sometimes it's not exactly so
approximately I'll say roughly 25% are
going to be in this second quartile
approximately 25% are going to be in the
third quartile and approximately 25% are
going to be in the fourth quartile so it
seems reasonable for saying 10 years old
or older that this is going to be this
is going to be true in fact you could
even have a couple of values in the
first quartile that are 10 but to make
that a little bit more tangible let's
look at some so I'm feeling I'm feeling
good that this is true but let's let's
look at a little few more examples to
make this a little bit more concrete so
they don't know we don't know based on
the information here exactly how many
students are at the party we'll have to
construct some scenarios so we could do
a scenario let's see if we can do we
could do a scenario where well let's see
let's see if I can I can construct
something where let's see the median is
13 we know that for sure
the median is 13 so if I have an odd
number I would have 13 in the middle
just like that and maybe I have 3 on
side and I'm just making that number up
I'm just trying to see what I can learn
about different types of datasets that
would could be described by this box and
whiskers plot so 10 is going to be the
middle of the bottom half so that's 10
right over there and 15 is going to be
the middle of the top half that's what
this box and whisker plot is telling us
and they of course tell us what the
minimum the minimum is 7 and they tell
us that the maximum is 16 so we know
that's seven and then that is 16 and
then this right over here could be
anything it could be 10 it could be 11
it could be 12 it could be 13 it
wouldn't change what these medians are
wouldn't change this box and whisker
plot
similarly this could be 13 it could be
14 it could be 15 and so any of those
values wouldn't change it and so 75% or
10 or older well this value 6 in this
case 6 out of 7 are 10 years old or
older and we could try it out with other
other scenarios where let's let's try 2
let's try to minimize the number of tens
given this data set well we could do
something like let's say that we have 8
so let's see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and so here
we know that the minimum we know that
the minimum is 7 we know that the
maximum is 16 we know we know that the
we know that the mean of these middle
two values we have an e and we have an
even number now so the median is going
to be the mean of these two values so
it's going to be the mean of this and
this is going to be 13 and we know that
the mean of we know that the mean of
this and this is going to be 10 and that
the mean of this and this is going to be
is going to be 15 so what could we
construct well actually we don't even
have to construct to answer this
question we know that we know that this
is going this is going to have to be 10
or larger and then all of these other
things are going to be 10 or larger so
this is exactly 75 percent exactly 75
percent if we assume that this is less
than 10 are going to be 10 years old or
older so feeling very good
very good about this one right over here
and actually just to make this concrete
I'll put in some values here you know
this could be this could be a nine and
an eleven this could be a twelve and a
fourteen this could be a fourteen and a
sixteen or it could be it could be a
fifteen and a fifteen you could think
about it in in any of those in any of
those ways but feeling very good that
this is definitely going to be true
based on the information given in this
in this plot now they say there's only
one seven-year-old at the party one
seven-year-old of the party well this
first this first possibility that we
looked at that was the case there was
only one seven-year-old of the party and
there was one sixteen-year-old of the
party and actually that was the next
date 'men there's only one
sixteen-year-old of the party so both of
these seems like we can definitely
construct data that's consistent with
this box plot box and whiskers plot
where this is true but could we
construct one where it's not true well
sure let's imagine let's see we have our
median at 13 meeting at 13 and then we
have let's see one two three four five
one two three four five this is going to
be this is going to be the ten the
median of this bottom half this is going
to be 15 this is going to be seven this
is going to be 16 well this could also
be seven it doesn't have to be could be
seven eight nine or ten this could also
be 16 doesn't have to be it could be 15
as well but just like that I've
constructed a data set and these could
be you know this could be 10 11 12 13
this could be 10 11 12 13 this could be
13 14 15 this cone also it could be 13
14 15 but the simple thing is or the the
basic idea here I can have a data set
where I have multiple 7's and multiple
16s or I could have a data set we only
have one seven or only one sixteen so
this both of these statements we just
plain don't know we just don't we just
don't know now the next statement
exactly half the students are older than
13 well if you look at this possibility
up here we
that we saw that three out of the seven
are older than 13 so that's not exactly
half three sevens is not one half but in
this one over here we did see that
exactly half our old are over are older
than 13 in fact if you're saying exactly
hat well in this one we're seeing that
exactly half are older than 13 we have
an even number right over here and so it
is exactly half so it's possible that
it's true it's possible that's not true
based on the information given we once
again we once again don't we once again
do not know anyway hopefully you found
this interesting this is the whole point
of me doing this is you know when you
look at statistics sometimes it's easy
to kind of say okay I think it roughly
means that and that's sometimes okay but
it's very important to think about what
types of actual statements you can make
and what you can't make it's very
important when you're looking at
statistics to say well you know what I
just don't know that the data actually
is not telling me that thing for sure